who's true love and justice does not
smile upon bigotry this bill is a fraud
rejoice in the freedom we have been
granted we need not legalize something
that is already occurring on a daily
basis all in favor say aye ah any
opposed the eyes have it I mean already
Arkansas has this reputation Viet
deserved or undeserved of being a
somewhat backward state and frankly as a
person from Arkansas in Arkansas native
that hurts me to hear it violates my
religious freedom as an out LGBT
Christian being LGBT and Arkansas you
know it's already very difficult I have
experienced employment discrimination
I've come to conclusion that it would be
helpful to move legislation this week
that makes it clear that this law does
not give businesses a right to deny
services to any